This is the 99% of visible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Joe. Today we are discussing Article 3, which establishes the judicial branch of the federal government. Article 3 is much shorter than the first two articles that we've covered so far. It begins. The judicial power of the United States shall be vested in one Supreme Court and in such inferior courts as the Congress may from time to time ordain and establish. The judges, both of the Supreme and inferior courts, shall hold their offices during good behavior and shall, at stated times, receive for their services a compensation, which shall not be diminished during their continuance in office.
这是宪法中可见部分中占99%的内容。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是伊丽莎白·乔。今天我们讨论第三条，它确立了联邦政府的司法分支。第三条比我们迄今为止讨论的前两条要短得多。它是这样开头的：“美利坚合众国的司法权，应置于一个最高法院以及国会随时下令设立的低级法院。最高法院和低级法院的法官，如果表现良好，得继续任职，并应在规定时间内获得服务报酬，在其任职期间，该报酬不得减少。”
Article 3 goes on to talk about the jurisdiction of the federal courts, or which types of cases they're allowed to hear. These include disputes about treaties, federal laws, and, of course, the Constitution. But just as important as what's in Article 3. 3 is what is not in Article 3. More on that later. Our guest for this episode is Adam Liptack, who covers the Supreme Court and other legal issues for the New York Times. He started his career as a lawyer before transitioning to reporting almost 25 years ago. Adam's depth of knowledge about the Supreme Court and Article 3 makes him the perfect guest. We talk about the legacy of the Roberts Court, why reforming the court is so difficult and what it's like to be a Supreme Court reporter.
第三条接着讨论了联邦法院的管辖权，或者说它们有权审理哪些类型的案件。这些包括有关条约、联邦法律以及当然还有宪法的争端。但与第三条包含的内容同样重要的是，第三条中没有包含的内容。稍后我们将详细探讨。我们本期的嘉宾是亚当·利普塔克，他为《纽约时报》报道最高法院和其他法律问题。在大约25年前转行做新闻报道之前，他曾以律师身份开启职业生涯。亚当对最高法院和第三条的深厚知识使他成为完美的嘉宾。我们讨论了罗伯茨法院的遗产、为什么改革法院如此困难，以及作为一名最高法院记者是怎样的体验。
But we start with what Adam believes surprises people most about this part of the Constitution. I guess they think that it's an elaborate description of our sprawling federal judicial system, when in fact all it does is create a Supreme Court, it doesn't even specify its size, and it leaves to Congress a lot of the detail work. Yeah. And so what are some of the important things that we should? should know about this part of the Constitution? Well, I think a key point is that it's Article 3, which is to say that the framers envisioned
但我们从亚当认为最让人对宪法这部分感到意外的地方开始。我想人们认为它是对我们庞大的联邦司法体系的详细描述，但实际上它所做的只是建立了一个最高法院，它甚至没有明确法院的规模，并将许多细节工作留给了国会。是的。那么，关于宪法的这一部分，我们应该了解哪些重要的事情呢？嗯，我认为一个关键点是它是第三条，也就是说，制定者们设想
Congress has been taking the lead role. It's a little hard for us these days to imagine that, you know, a muscular legislature was supposed to be the primary actor in the constitutional structure, the lead actor. Article 2, an energetic president executing the laws that Congress enacted. And then bringing up the rear, what some of the framers called the least dangerous branch, its role kind of uncertain, not a very appealing job at first. People didn't particularly want to be Supreme Court justices. You know, the Supreme Court, which we'll talk about this, over time, has taken on great status.
国会将会发挥主导作用。如今我们很难想象，一个强有力的立法机关本应是宪法结构中的主要行为者，即领衔行为者。第二条设想了一个精力充沛的总统去执行国会制定的法律。然后殿后的是一些制定者称之为“最不危险的分支”，它的角色有点不确定，起初并不是一个很有吸引力的工作。人们并不是特别想成为最高法院大法官。你知道的，最高法院——我们稍后会讨论这一点——随着时间的推移，已经获得了很高的地位
and power. But in the beginning was almost an afterthought as a way to, you know, adjudicate a small set of disputes between, say, citizens of different states. Well, maybe that's something we could talk a bit more about. You mentioned Congress having a role. So maybe people don't quite understand what that, at least theoretical power is. So how much power does Congress have over the Supreme Court? Well, for instance, it can set the size of the Supreme Court. That's by legislation. don't need a constitutional amendment. It has been as small as five, as large as 10, and some of that court packing, call it, and court shrinking has been done for political reasons. Now, it's been steady at nine for a long time, and that norm may stick, although there was a lot of talk
和权力。但一开始它几乎是一个事后诸葛亮式的存在，只是为了裁决一小部分争端，比如，不同州公民之间的争端。嗯，也许这是我们可以多聊聊的一个话题。你提到国会扮演着某种角色。所以也许人们并不十分理解这种至少是理论上的权力到底是什么。那么国会对最高法院有多大的权力？嗯，例如，它可以设定最高法院的规模。这是通过立法实现的。不需要宪法修正案。它的规模曾小到五人，大到十人，其中一些所谓的“塞满法院”和“缩减法院”的做法是出于政治原因而进行的。现在，它长期稳定在九人，这种规范可能会坚持下去，尽管有很多讨论
in the Biden years from the left that the court should be expanded because of progressives on happiness with some of the Supreme Court's decisions. But that's one respect. in which Congress has a lot of power. It has some power. It's sort of undested in telling the court what cases it can hear. And jurisdiction stripping is a thing. For instance, in the realm of habeas corpus law, it has told the court and lower courts what kinds of cases can be brought in federal court and what cannot.
在拜登执政期间，左翼人士认为应该扩大法院规模，因为进步派对最高法院的一些裁决感到不满。但这是国会拥有很大权力的一方面。它在告诉法院可以审理哪些案件方面拥有一定的权力。而且剥夺管辖权也是切实存在的。例如，在人身保护令法律领域，它曾告诉最高法院和下级法院，哪些类型的案件可以在联邦法院提起，哪些不能。
Maybe we could pause for a moment and sort of expand that for folks who might not be familiar with this idea. What is jurisdiction stripping exactly? Well, for starters, the Supreme Court doesn't get to decide every case in the world. It only gets to decide cases arising from federal law or the Constitution, with some scattered exceptions. But it's not a court of general jurisdiction. And then Congress can also tell it that it can decide some sorts of cases and not others. And so how far Congress can go down that road is quite untested,
也许我们可以暂停一下，为那些可能不熟悉这个概念的人稍微展开讲讲。到底什么是剥夺管辖权？嗯，首先，最高法院并非可以审理世上所有的案件。它只能审理源于联邦法律或宪法的案件，只有少数零星的例外。但它不是一个具有一般管辖权的法院。而且国会也可以告诉它，它可以审理某些类别的案件，而不能审理其他类别的案件。所以国会在这条路上能走多远还未经过充分检验，
but it can go down the road at least some part of the way. So, you know, we talk about the separation of powers, but the three branches also have intersecting powers. And Congress's power in shaping the Supreme Court and the federal court system is pretty substantial. So I know that over the years, members of Congress have proposed things like we want to make sure that the federal courts maybe can hear issues on school desegregation or abortion or school prayer. So these come up, I think, for political reasons, but they never get very far.
但它至少可以走通这条路的一部分。所以，你知道，我们谈论三权分立，但三个分支也拥有交织的权力。而且国会在塑造最高法院和联邦法院系统方面的权力是相当巨大的。所以我知道多年来，国会议员们曾提出过诸如我们希望确保联邦法院能够审理有关学校取消隔离、堕胎或学校祈祷等问题。所以这些问题的出现，我认为是出于政治原因，但它们从未真正取得实质进展。
And I've always been curious why Congress has never gone maybe as far as it possibly could and test those limits. I don't know if you have a view on that. I think it's a kind of deep American norm that it would be untoward. it would be unseemly, it would be unjust to do it. But I'm not sure that the Constitution wouldn't allow it. I think probably if Congress were to do something along those lines, perhaps in an uncontroversial area like patent law, it ought to have to be prospective.
我一直很好奇为什么国会从未尽可能地走得更远去检验这些界限。我不知道你对此有什么看法。我认为这是一种根深蒂固的美国规范，即这样做是不合宜的、不得体的、不公正的。但我并不确定宪法是否不允许这样做。我想，如果国会真的要沿着这些路线做些什么，也许在一个没有争议的领域，比如专利法，它应该是前瞻性的。
It would be problematic probably for Congress to say that in pending cases, the court has to do X or Y. Although there are cases that reach the court. where statutes are quite specific, including by docket number, saying that they have to be resolved one way or the other. And the court has basically gone along with those congressional enactments. So your larger point, Elizabeth, is quite right, that we don't know how much power Congress has,
对于国会来说，在正处于审理中的案件中说法院必须做这样或那样的事情，可能会是有问题的。尽管有些案件到达了法院，其中法规非常具体，甚至带有了案号，要求必须以某种方式解决。而法院基本上也顺应了国会的这些立法。所以伊丽莎白，你的宏观观点是完全正确的，我们并不知道国会拥有多大的权力，
but Congress hasn't tried to exercise it very much. Right. I mean, I think maybe some of the most significant cases about jurisdiction stripping and even taking some cases away, even from the Supreme Court itself, you know, the biggest ones go all the way back to the Civil War era. And that suggests that there's some, as you mentioned, the timidity or kind of uncertainty is Congress being reluctant to force that issue as far as it can go.
但国会并没有试图过多地行使它。对的。我的意思是，我认为关于剥夺管辖权甚至剥夺某些案件审理权（甚至包括最高法院自身的审理权）的一些最重大的案件，其中最大的那些可以一直追溯到内战时期。这表明正如你所提到的，国会存在某种羞怯或某种不确定性，不愿将这个问题推向它所能达到的极限。
And maybe you're suggesting that if Congress were to go that far, maybe that would really be a pointer of, that would really point us to some sort of constitutional crisis moment. Oh, if we haven't reached that already. Right. Well, also, the political branches are accountable to the electorate, and it's entirely possible that people wouldn't put up with it, just as FDR, who could not have been more popular in the polls and commanded supermajorities of support in both houses,
也许你在暗示，如果国会真的走得那么远，那可能真的是某种宪法危机时刻的指向标，会真正为我们指明方向。哦，如果我们还没有达到那种地步的话。没错。嗯，还有，政治分支对选民负责，人们完全有可能不买账，正如罗斯福总统在民意调查中的支持率再高不过，并且在两院都拥有压倒性的支持超级多数，
couldn't get court packing done because the public wouldn't put up with it. So, I mean, one reason politicians may not do it is because it's at least possible the public won't stand for it. But also, like, the Congress wouldn't stand for it. Like, it wasn't, like, all locked step behind the executive back then. Yeah, well, we do live in different times. And that's also, we talked about the authority of Congress to maybe limit the kinds of cases that the federal courts and even the Supreme Court itself can hear. But, you know, we should also mention here, Congress has a great deal of power over the very structure and funding of the courts.
也没能成功扩充法院规模，因为公众不买账。所以，我的意思是，政治人物可能不这么做的一个原因，是至少公众有可能无法容忍这一点。但同时，就像国会也不会容忍一样。就像当时它并没有和行政部门完全步调一致一样。是的，好吧，我们确实生活在不同的时代。这也是——我们讨论过国会有权限制联邦法院甚至最高法院本身可以审理的案件类型。但是，我们在这里也应该提到，国会对法院的整体结构和资金拥有巨大的权力。
And I guess that too could be a kind of source of power or control from Congress. But we haven't seen too much of that either. Is that right? Right. This came up a little bit, and it's basically political statements. But the question of whether you can impeach judges and justices because you don't like their rulings was kind of tested early in the life of the Republic. and the consensus view after Samuel Chase was impeached by the House but acquitted by the Senate was that we're not going to have that kind of system, which in much of the world happens.
我想这也是国会权力和控制的一种来源。但我们也并没有看到太多这样的情况。是这样吗？是的。这一点在某种程度上被提出过，它基本上是政治声明。但是，是否可以因为你不喜欢法官和大法官的裁决而弹劾他们，这个问题在共和国建立初期曾受到过某种程度的考验，而在众议院弹劾塞缪尔·蔡斯但参议院宣告其无罪之后，共识性的观点是，我们不会采用那种体制——而在世界许多地方，这种情况是会发生的。
You sort of get new judges with a new administration. And we will impeach judges for authentic misconduct, but not for disagreement with how they've ruled, or at least not so far. So we've talked about that there isn't a lot in Article III, but of the stuff that is in Oracle 3, What are some of the important things that you would teach your students, Elizabeth, for example, and what should we know? Well, certainly some of the topics we've just discussed this idea that Congress does have a significant role, which it hasn't always exercised to its most extreme in the kinds of cases that the federal courts in general and the Supreme Court can hear. What's also in Article 3 is this idea that the federal courts are courts of limited jurisdiction. And that's just a fancy way you're saying.
随着新政府的到来，你往往会迎来新的法官。而我们只会因真正的失职行为弹劾法官，而不会因为不同意他们的裁决而弹劾，或者至少目前为止还没有。所以我们讨论过，第三条中并没有包含太多内容，但在第三条确实包含的内容中，伊丽莎白，例如你会教给学生哪些重要的事情，我们又应该了解什么？嗯，当然包括我们刚刚讨论过的一些主题：国会确实发挥了重要作用（尽管它并不总是将其发挥到极致），即决定联邦法院总体上以及最高法院可以审理哪些案件。第三条中还包含这样一种观点：联邦法院是有限管辖权的法院。这只是一种高级的说法，意思就是说
The federal courts can't actually hear every single kind of case. You know, your average slip and fall, your contract dispute. Generally, those are for the state courts. And in fact, most of the criminal justice cases in the country are within the state court systems rather than federal courts. So as powerful as we think the federal judiciary is, and it is, it actually can only hear a circumscribed number in different types of cases. So that's really important. And then I think, you know, so much of this is. thinking about how the court itself has interpreted the very part of the Constitution that regulates it.
联邦法院实际上并不能审理每一种案件。你知道的，你平常碰到的滑倒摔伤案、合同纠纷案。通常这些是留给州法院处理的。事实上，国内大多数刑事司法案件都在州法院系统内，而不是联邦法院。因此，尽管我们认为联邦司法机构有多么强大（它确实很强大），但实际上它只能审理数量有限、类型不同的案件。所以这真的很重要。然后我认为，你知道，其中很大一部分内容是
You know, the Article 3 is just six paragraphs. So there's not a whole lot there. I might point to a distinctive feature of the American federal judicial system, which is that judges, both of the Supreme and inferior courts, shall hold their offices during good behavior, which is to say that they have life tenure. Yeah. Yeah, they can be impeached, but otherwise they get to decide when they will step down.
思考法院本身是如何解释宪法中规范其自身的这一部分的。你知道的，第三条只有六个段落。所以并没有太多内容。我可能会指出美国联邦司法体系的一个独特特征，那就是无论是最高法院还是下级法院的法官，只要表现良好就可以任职，也就是说他们享有终身任职权。对的。是的，他们可以被弹劾，但除此之外，他们可以自行决定何时卸任。
We are the only developed nation in the world without either a mandatory retirement age or term limits. And that is not widely thought to be a good thing. It leads to questions about people serving longer than they should, about cognitive decline. and it also injects an element of politics at the back end of Supreme Court service. It's bad enough that Supreme Court justices are appointed through an intensely political process dominated by a politician, the president, confirmed by 100 politicians, the Senate. But then this idea of good behavior ought to give them a measure of independence and also that their pay can't be diminished.
我们是世界上唯一没有强制退休年龄或任期限制的发达国家。人们普遍不认为这是一件好事。这导致了人们对一些人超期服役、认知能力下降的质疑，并且在最高法院任职的后期注入了政治因素。最高法院大法官是通过一个由政客（总统）主导、并由100名政客（参议院）确认的极具政治化的过程被任命的，这已经够糟糕的了。但随后这种“表现良好”的理念本应赋予他们一定程度的独立性，而且他们的薪酬不能被削减。
So that's meant to insulate them from politics. But then on the back end of their careers, they get to decide whom they're going to retire under. And they tend to try to retire under a president whose politics are sympathica with their own. And that brings an element of politics as a kind of bookend to this process. And, you know, I guess I submit to that,
所以这本意是让他们免受政治干扰。但在他们职业生涯的后期，他们可以自行决定在哪个总统任期内退休。他们往往会试图在一位政治立场与他们相契合的总统任期内退休。这就为这个过程的收尾阶段引入了政治因素。而且，你知道，我想我承认这一点，
That's problematic and unfortunate. Yeah, yeah. And since this is one part that actually is in the Constitution or could be interpreted that way, if you were to consider term limits for Supreme Court justices, that would actually require an amendment. Is that correct? Yes, that's right.
这是有问题且不幸的。是的，是的。既然这是宪法中实际存在的或者可以被这样解释的一部分，如果你考虑为最高法院大法官设定任期限制，那实际上需要一项修正案。对吗？是的，没错。
Yeah. So it's kind of a weird paradox or incompatibility or something where the reform that is widely accepted by the public, and legal scholars and so on of term limits or mandatory retirement age requires a constitutional amendment, which means it ain't never going to happen. Exactly. Right. Like the proper remedy is the hardest one to actually get done.
是的。所以这是一种奇怪的悖论、不兼容性或者诸如此类的情况，即公众、法律学者等普遍接受的关于任期限制或强制退休年龄的改革，需要通过宪法修正案，这意味着它永远不会发生。完全正确。就像正确的救济手段恰恰是最难真正做到的那个。
Whereas expanding the size of the court, many people think is a bad idea because it will just result in a kind of tit-for-tat expansion and we'll have a Supreme Court of 90 people. and at least the current Supreme Court thinks that the phrase in the Constitution there shall be one Supreme Court means that they have to sit in a single panel. It would become pretty unwieldy, pretty quick. But that doesn't require a constitutional amendment. That can be done by simple majorities of the two houses. Yeah, I think actually one effect of the life tenure of all federal judges,
而扩大法院的规模，许多人认为是个坏主意，因为它只会导致针锋麦对的持续扩张，最终我们可能会拥有一个由90人组成的最高法院，并且至少目前的最高法院认为宪法中“应设立一个最高法院”这一短语意味着他们必须作为一个单一合议庭开庭。那将会变得相当笨拙，而且非常快。但这并不需要宪法修正案。这可以通过两院的简单多数来完成。是的，我认为实际上所有联邦法官（包括最高法院大法官）终身任职的一个影响是，
including the Supreme Court justices, is that they subsequently attain this kind of celebrity. They serve for so long that a lot of people, though not all, of course, a lot of people know who the justices are. And that seems so at odds with some of the statements that I remember from Roberts' confirmation hearings. You know, he famously said the job of a judge is to call balls and strikes. But the thing that struck me in particular is that he says before the Senate, nobody ever went to a ball game to see the umpire. But it strikes me that that's your whole job, isn't it, to watch the U. empire in this case.
他们随后获得了这种名流般的地位。他们任职时间如此之长，以至于很多人（当然并非全部）都知道大法官是谁。这与我记忆中罗伯茨确认听证会上的某些陈述大相径庭。你知道，他曾名言道，法官的职责就是好比叫好球和坏球。但特别让我震撼的是，他在参议院面前说，从来没有人去棒球比赛是为了看裁判。但我觉得这恰恰是你的全部工作，不是吗？在这个案例中，你的工作就是盯着裁判。
Also, I mean, they wear black robes to signify a kind of anonymity and disinterestedness and this passion and this idea that they go on book tours and go on TV and go on TV kind of slanted in the ideological direction that their rulings might suggest. I don't think the framers envision that. Right. And Chief Justice Roberts' term has coincidental. with your time at the New York Times reporting on the court. So, you know, my question is, well, what do you think are some of the most important ways that the Roberts court has changed our understanding of the Constitution itself from your vantage point, from your long tenure, watching them?
此外，我的意思是，他们穿黑袍是为了象征一种匿名性、无私性、超然性，以及这种理念：他们去进行图书巡回宣传，上电视，并在电视上倾向于他们的裁决可能暗示的意识形态方向。我不认为制定者们曾设想过这一点。没错。而且罗伯茨首席大法官的任期与你在《纽约时报》报道法院的时间恰好重合。所以，你知道，我的问题是，从你的视角来看，从你长期观察他们的经历来看，你认为罗伯茨法院改变我们对宪法本身理解的最重要方式有哪些？
Well, that's a big question, and it's hard to give a general answer. Sure. I guess, so two thoughts come to mind that you think of the Roberts Court as an unbroken 20-21 year. entity. But really, I'd separated out with the Kennedy years where it was a 5-4 court that leaned right, but not always with Justice Kennedy in the middle, who would, you know, more than occasionally join the then-for-liberals in cases on abortion, affirmative action, the death penalty, and especially gay rights to deliver liberal victories. So you had a court that seemed, to a lot of people to be more balanced.
嗯，这是一个宏大的问题，很难给出一个笼统的回答。当然。我想，有两个想法浮现在脑海中：你可能会认为罗伯茨法院是一个连续20到21年的整体。但实际上，我会把它与肯尼迪法官在任的那些年区分开来，当时它是一个向右倾斜的5比4法院，但并不总是由肯尼迪法官居中斡旋——他会（你知道的）时不时地加入当时的四位自由派阵营，在堕胎、平权行动、死刑，特别是同性恋权利等案件中，为自由派带来胜利。所以你曾拥有一个在许多人看来更加平衡的法院。
And then with his retirement and the appointment of three Trump justices, you enter a different era where it's more lopsided and predictable. The other thing I might say about the Roberts era is that what some people call the democracy docket has kind of gone in one direction with the Rucho redistricting case, the Citizens United Campaign Finance case. the Shelby County case on the Voting Rights Act, all seeming to make it harder for the less powerful to have an influence in the democratic process. And, you know, that's the democracy docket. And I think a lot of folks are turning now to the court's decisions during the second Trump administration.
然后在他的退休和三位特朗普任命的大法官加入后，你进入了一个更加偏颇和可预测的不同时代。关于罗伯茨时代，我还可以说的另一件事是，有些人所说的民主案件诉讼日程表似乎朝着一个方向发展，比如“鲁丘”选区划分案、“联合公民”竞选资金案、《投票权法案》的“谢尔比县”案，所有这些似乎都让权力较小的人更难在民主进程中产生影响。而且，你知道，这就是民主诉讼日程表。并且我认为很多人现在正转向法院在特朗普第二任期内的裁决。
And do you have a sense of what is the Roberts Court's view of the presidency that you have observed? Like, what's the view of what the executive branch, the extent of its powers are? You know, it may well be that the most important decision of the entire Roberts' tenure is Trump against United States, the immunity decision. Partly because of the practical impact of ensuring that then candidate Trump wasn't tried on the charges Jack Smith brought against them. but more for its vision of unbridled executive power, which maps onto or maybe even emboldened President Trump to pursue his maximalist vision of executive power.
你是否对罗伯茨法院对总统职位的看法有所感知？比如，你观察到它对行政分支及其权力范围的看法是什么？你知道的，整个罗伯茨任期内最重大的裁决很可能就是“特朗普诉合众国案”，也就是豁免权裁决。部分原因在于它确保了当时的候选人特朗普不会因杰克·史密斯对他的指控而受审的实际影响，但更多的是因为它对不受约束的行政权力的愿景，这与特朗普总统追求其行政权力最大化愿景的理念相契合，甚至可能鼓舞了这一愿景。
That decision is in tension with Elizabeth, the kind of balls and strikes version of judging that you described. And I don't know that it is a matter of judicial craft. it was the Chief Justice's finest hour. And then you have this spade of, you know, more than 20 decisions on what critics call the shadow docket, these emergency orders that raced to the court on thin briefs and typically no oral argument and decided often in a matter of weeks with sometimes no reasoning and sometimes very scant reasoning. Where Trump has won the vast majority of them, he did face a setback. in the Illinois National Guard deployment case.
这一裁决与伊丽莎白你所描述的那种裁判式的审判观点存在张力。我不知道这是否是一个法律工艺的问题，这曾是首席大法官的高光时刻。然后你又遇到了这一系列（你知道的）批评者所谓的影子 docket（影子日程表）上的20多项裁决，这些是在简短的简报、通常没有口头辩论的情况下冲向最高法院的紧急命令，通常在几周内做出决定，有时没有理由，有时理由非常少。其中特朗普赢得了绝大多数案件，不过他在伊利诺伊州国民警卫队部署案中确实遭遇了一次挫折。
He may well lose on the merits docket on the argued cases in the tariffs case, in the birthright citizenship case, maybe even on his attempt to fire Lisa Cook, the Fed governor. So it may be that by the end of the term, we have a more balanced perspective on the Roberts Court. But currently, President Trump is getting almost everything he wants out of this court.
在关税案、出生公民权案的实质辩论案件日程表中，甚至在他试图解雇美联储理事丽莎·库克的尝试上，他很可能在实质审理案中输掉。因此，到本任期结束时，我们可能会对罗伯茨法院有一个更平衡的视角。但目前，特朗普总统几乎从这个法院得到了他想要的一切。
Right. step back for a moment, for those who aren't familiar, the idea of the merits docket is sort of the traditional view we have this of the Supreme Court, where lawyers file briefs, there's oral argument before the full court, there's some period of time in which we're all waiting for a decision, and then a majority opinion and perhaps concurrences and dissents are issued. Could you say more about what the emergency or shadow docket is for people who aren't familiar with that idea? It has many flavors, but the basic idea is this. A, perhaps, president initiates a new program. And all presidents do this, but not quite as aggressively as
好吧，退一步讲，对于那些不熟悉的人来说，实质审理案日程表的概念是我们对最高法院的传统看法：律师提交简报，在全体法官面前进行口头辩论，经过一段时间等待判决，然后发布多数意见，或许还有协同意见和不同意见。对于不熟悉这一概念的人，你能多讲讲什么是紧急日程表或影子日程表吗？它有多种形式，但基本概念是这样的。也许某位总统发起了一项新计划。所有的总统都会这样做，但没有哪位像特朗普总统在其第二任期内那样激进。
President Trump in his second term. Some executive order happens, and it's challenged in court. And let's say a trial judge says, I'm going to block it while the litigation goes forward. I think this is probably unlawful. I'm going to block it. And we'll figure out whether it's lawful over the next 18 months, two years. It takes a while to litigate this stuff. And so a presidential program is frozen, and that's, you know, that's a big deal. It goes up to an appeals court and the president's lawyer says, please unblock it. Please let this program go into effect while the litigation goes forward. And let's say the appeals court says, no, we're not going to stay the injunction. We're going to let the program remain blocked. And then it races up to the
某项行政命令出台了，并在法庭上受到质疑。比方说，初审法官说：“我要在诉讼进行期间阻止它。我认为这可能是违法的。我要阻止它。”我们将在未来18个月到两年内弄清楚它是否合法——审理这些事情需要一段时间。因此，总统的计划被冻结了，这（你知道的）是一件大事。案件上诉到上诉法院，总统的律师说：“请解除冻结。请让这个计划在诉讼进行期间生效。”假设上诉法院说：“不，我们不会暂缓禁令。我们要让该计划继续保持冻结状态。”然后案件迅速冲上
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court says, yay or nay. And all of this happens very fast. And in this preliminary posture, without the facts being fully developed, without the legal arguments being fully developed on thin briefing, one round of briefing, no oral arguments. My best understanding is the justices never meet to discuss the case. They exchanged some memos. And they give birth to an order which quite often is just a thumbs up, thumbs down, you win, you lose, often with elaborate dissents, but the actual opinion can have no reasoning or very slight reasoning. And then a recent development is that nonetheless lower courts are meant to treat these orders with like zero reasoning and binding precedent and make sense of them.
最高法院，最高法院说：“行或不行”。所有这一切都发生得非常快。在这种初步姿态下，在事实没有完全展开、法律论据没有完全展开、简报很薄、只有一轮简报、没有口头辩论的情况下。据我所知，大法官们从未开会讨论该案。他们交换了一些备忘录。然后他们炮制出了一项命令，通常只是一个大拇指向上或向下的表态：你赢了，你输了。通常会有详细的不同意见，但实际的意见可能没有理由或只有非常微弱的理由。然后最近出现的一个发展是，尽管如此，下级法院本应将这些几乎零理由的命令当作具有约束力的先例来对待，并从中理出头绪。
So, I mean, I don't think anybody's crazy about this shadow docket. Some people call it. Some people call it the emergency docket. Lately, the court likes to call it the interim docket. Some people call it the short order docket. It's not good in two senses. Nobody thinks the court does its best work on a rushed basis. Whatever else you can say about the court, its decisions on the merits document and the argued cases are reasoned
所以，我的意思是，我认为没有人会为这个影子日程表疯狂。有些人称之为紧急日程表。最近，法院喜欢称之为临时日程表。有些人称之为快速命令日程表。它在两个意义上都不是好事。没有人认为法院在仓促的基础上能做出最好的工作。不管你对法院有什么其他看法，它在实质日程表和有辩论的案件上的裁决都是经过论证的、
and engaged and tell you what the basis for the ruling is, and these shadow-docket rulings do not. And also, I mean, just as a general idea of the nature of law, is that the political branches claim legitimacy by dint of having been elected, by dint of democracy. The judicial branch claims legitimacy by dint of reason, by dint of persuasion. And when that's missing, it's hard to see how the branch is legitimate at all.
且参与其中的，并且会告诉你裁决的依据是什么，而这些影子日程表的裁决则不然。而且，我的意思是，仅就法律的本质这一普遍概念而言，政治分支是通过选举产生、通过民主来宣称其合法性的。而司法分支则是通过理性、通过说服来宣称其合法性的。当这一点缺失时，很难看出这个分支究竟还有什么合法性。
I guess one question is just to look at the sheer amount of wins that the Trump administration has had on the emergency docket. Is there anything other than pure partisanship that can explain that just the fact that the Trump administration generally will tend to win in these cases? I think the conservative justices are just, generally inclined to defer to the executive branch. And I'd like to say whether the president is Republican or Democratic, but the political science data don't quite bear that out.
我想一个问题就是看看特朗普政府在紧急日程表上获得的巨大胜诉数量。除了纯粹的党派偏向之外，还有什么能解释这一点——仅仅是特朗普政府在这些案件中往往会获胜这一事实吗？我认为保守派大法官们通常倾向于顺从行政分支。我想说，无论总统是共和党人还是民主党人，但政治学数据并不完全支持这一点。
Yeah. Well, I have a shadow docket. It seems like the whole system that was established with Article III is a slow system. It's not meant for things to happen quickly. Is there any reason why or any reason why not that they should just refuse all these things? So I have conflicting thoughts. On the one hand, it is a little surprising that a single district court judge who might well have been, you know, if not selected by the litigants, at least sitting in a place. You know, if you're a Republican, you go to Texas.
是的。好吧，我有关于影子日程表的疑问，整个与第三条建立起来的系统似乎是一个缓慢的系统。它本来就不是为快速发生事情而设计的。它们为什么应该或不应该拒绝所有这些事情呢？所以我有矛盾的想法。一方面，有点令人惊讶的是，一个单一的地方法院法官——如果不是由诉讼当事人挑选的话，至少也是坐在某个地方（如果你是共和党人，你就去得克萨斯州；
If you're a Democrat, you go to San Francisco or Boston. You're likely to get someone kind of favorable to you. And that that person, that single judge, should be able to decide for a matter of maybe years to shut down a major initiative of an elected leader of a great nation. That might be a decision for the Supreme Court to make. On the other hand, the Supreme Court's general attitude on the merits docket, on the usual docket, on the argued case docket,
如果你是民主党人，你就去旧金山或波士顿，你很可能会遇到一个对你比较有利的人）——而这个人，这个单一的法官，居然能够决定关闭一个伟大国家的民选领导人的重大倡议，一停就是几年之久。这或许应该是最高法院来做出的决定。另一方面，最高法院在实质日程表、在日常日程表、在有辩论的案件日程表上的普遍态度
is our default is we don't take the case. It may have been wrongly decided. But we take one out of 100 cases. And you file your petition, you take your chances, and we don't do error correction. We only decide cases that either have divided the lower courts or are really important. And I think at least,
是：我们的默认立场是我们不接案。它可能被判错了。但我们在100个案件中只接一个。你提交你的请愿书，你碰运气，我们不做纠错。我们只裁决那些下级法院存在分歧或真正重要的案件。我认为至少
in some of these shadow docket cases, that kind of attitude that let's let this play out, and as you were saying, Roman, we'll get to it when we get to it. It'll reach us in the fullness of time. Well, I think that's, you know, one tension here, though, is that that is the traditional view of the courts in general and the Supreme Court in particular. But what seems to me notable about Trump's second term is just the sheer amount of conduct that seems to be challenged in court. And it's almost an attempt to flood the zone of things that raise all kinds of legal and
在其中一些影子日程表案件中，那种“让事情顺其自然”的态度——正如你所说的，罗曼，我们到时自然会处理，它会在成熟的时机到达我们手里。好吧，我认为（你知道的）这里的其中一个张力在于，那是法院总体上尤其是最高法院的传统看法。但对我来说，特朗普第二任期引人注目的一点是，在法庭上受到质疑的行为数量庞大。这几乎是一种企图，旨在用引发各种法律和
constitutional questions. But that seems like a tactic that is deliberately intended to overwhelm the courts. I don't know if you have a sense of that kind of dynamic happening right now. So it's complicated. And it starts at the root. I mean, the root is that the administration has issued more executive orders than anybody else. and that gives rise to a lot of litigation and a bunch of that litigation reaches the Supreme Court.
宪法问题的事情来“淹没阵地”。但这似乎是一种蓄意旨在压垮法院的策略。我不知道你是否对当前发生的这种动态有所感知。所以情况很复杂。它始于根源。我的意思是，根源在于行政当局发布的行政命令比任何人都多，这引发了大量的诉讼，其中一堆诉讼最终到达了最高法院。
But there is a kind of funnel. And while the Justice Department in general is not doing great work these days, the unit of the Justice Department that litigates before the Supreme Court, the Solicitor General's Office, continues to be an elite, classy outfit. And it's been quite strategic in the cases it takes to the court.
但存在某种漏斗效应。虽然司法部总体上最近表现不佳，但司法部中在最高法院进行辩论的机构——总检察长办公室——继续保持着精英、一流的作风。而且它在接手诉讼到法院时非常具有战略眼光。
And it's possible to overstate this, but one reason why it's been as successful as it has been is that it's picked its best cases. It hasn't taken every case to the Supreme Court. It didn't, for instance, initially take the merits of the birthright citizenship case to the Supreme Court. It has slow walked its preposterous cases attacking law firms. And it's taken cases to the court where the court is all wrong. already in earlier years indicated that it's sympathetic to the point of view, for instance, that the president can remove leaders of independent agencies. That's not like a Trump idea. That's a Republican idea.
虽然有点夸大其词，但它之所以能取得如此成功的一个原因在于它挑选了最好的案件。它并没有把每一个案件都带到最高法院。例如，它最初并没有将出生公民权案的实质问题带到最高法院。它缓慢推进了那些攻击律所的荒谬案件。它将那些法院在早些年已经表明持同情观点的案件带到了最高法院，例如总统可以免除独立机构领导人的观点。这不像是特朗普的想法。这是一个共和党人的想法。
We have to take a break. When we come back, we talk about the modern Supreme Court's main function, which is not in the Constitution. So we've been talking a lot about, basically about judicial review, about what the Supreme Court does. And this is a thing that is not an article. Can we talk about the fact that this is the major purpose as we've seen it in the court and is not present in the Constitution at all? Right. Well, I mean, without turning this into that class that baffles first year law students. Which I just taught, by the way.
我们必须休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将讨论现代最高法院的主要功能，而这个功能并不在宪法中。所以我们一直在讨论基本上是关于司法审查的事情，也就是最高法院做什么。这是一件不在宪法条款中的事情。我们可以谈谈这样一个事实：这是我们所看到的法院的主要目的，但它根本没有出现在宪法中吗？对的。嗯，我的意思是，在不把这变成那门让法学一年级学生感到困惑的课程的情况下……
Maybe you should tell the story of Martin v. Madison. I mean, John Marshall was the genius. And he sort of announced that. that the court gets to say what the law is. Now, I think when he announced it, and I'm curious about your views, Elizabeth, you know more about this than I do. But when he announced it,
顺便说一句，我刚教过这门课。也许你应该讲讲马伯里诉麦迪逊案的故事。我的意思是，约翰·马歇尔是个天才。他某种程度上宣布了法院有权说明法律是什么。现在，我认为当他宣布这一点时——我对你的观点很好奇，伊丽莎白，你对此比我了解得更多。但当他宣布这一点时，
I don't think he was announcing that it's the exclusive interpreter of what the law is. Members of the other branches have an independent obligation to assess their constitutional obligations. And only later did the court declare judicial supremacy, I think, in Cooper against Aaron. That's right. But this idea
我不认为他是在宣布它是法律含义的唯一解释者。其他分支的成员有独立的义务去评估他们的宪法义务。直到后来，法院才在库珀诉阿伦案中宣布了司法至上。没错。但这种想法
that this kind of third tag-along branch is actually going to take a leading role in telling people what the law is, as opposed to just deciding disputes. I mean, this came up in Trump against Casa,
即这种处于附属地位的第三分支实际上要在告诉人们法律是什么方面扮演主导角色，而不仅仅是解决争端。我的意思是，这在“特朗普诉卡萨案”中出现了，
which was the first version of the birthright citizenship case that didn't really involve birthright citizenship. It involved the of what is the power of district courts to impose so-called nationwide or universal injunctions, which is to say, can a district court not only bind the people before it, but also everybody else similarly situated. And in the process of arguing that case, the lawyer for the Trump administration, the Solicitor General John Sauer, is asked by several justices. like we get it.
这是出生公民权案的第一个版本，其实并不真正涉及出生公民权。它涉及的是地方法院施加所谓全国性或普遍性禁令的权力是什么，也就是说，地方法院不仅可以约束其面前的人，还可以约束其他处于类似情况的人吗？在辩论该案的过程中，特朗普政府的律师、总检察长约翰·绍尔被几位大法官问到：
This record can't do that, and that is how they came out of the end. But if we were to say that not only are the people in front of us bound by our opinion, but everybody else is, that's true, isn't it? And he said, oh, yeah, that's true. This is a pretty important. Right. Well, you know, it's funny. It happens to be a very convenient way for the court to also consolidate its own authority and power, of course.
就像我们懂的。这份记录不能这样做，而这也是他们最终得出的结果。但如果我们说，不仅我们面前的人受我们意见的约束，其他人也都受约束，那是真的，对吧？他说：“哦，是的，那是真的。”这是一个相当重要的……。对的。嗯，你知道，这很有趣。这碰巧也是法院巩固自身权威和权力的一种非常方便的方式，当然。
And this concept of judicial review, that not only do they interpret the Constitution, but they have the final say, which we could only ever disagree with through constitutional amendment, which rarely ever happens, of course. And that means that there are only a few theoretical limits to what the court can do.
而且这种司法审查的概念——不仅他们解释宪法，而且他们拥有最终决定权，而我们唯一能对之表示不同意见的方式是通过宪法修正案，而这当然很少发生——这意味着对于法院能做什么，只有几个理论上的限制。
And that seems to be things like starry decisis, this idea, the reluctance to overturn prior precedent. But I have to say that, you know, it seems like there's a lot of instability happening right now in our sense of constitutional law. So, you know, for example, in my syllabus the semester, I actually have a section where I've told the students, this might not be good law by the time we get to it, the section on appointment and removals.
这似乎包括“遵循先例”这样的东西，这种理念，即不愿推翻先前的先例。但我必须说，（你知道的）我们的宪法法律意识现在似乎正在发生很多不稳定性。所以，你知道，例如在我这学期的教学大纲中，我其实有一个部分，我告诉学生：当我们讲到它时，这可能已经不再是好法律了，也就是关于任命和免职的那一部分。
And part of this is because we know the court is comfortable overturning even longstanding precedent, you know, Dobbs, a case that overturned a woman's right to an abortion in 2022 is maybe the chief example here. So how do you, what do you? you make of the court's attitude to this idea story decisis. I don't know that the Roberts Court is any worse than earlier courts in overturning earlier decisions. Just as a matter of counting the cases in which it's used the words we overrule X, it's done that at a similar and slightly lower pace than earlier courts. Now, that doesn't take account of the
部分原因是因为我们知道法院乐于推翻甚至长期的先例——你知道的，2022年推翻女性堕胎权的“多布斯案”也许就是主要的例子。所以你如何看待法院对“遵循先例”这一概念的态度？我不认为罗伯茨法院在推翻先前裁决方面比以往的法院更糟糕。仅仅从计算它使用“我们推翻X”这个词的案件数量来看，它的节奏与以往的法院相似，甚至略低。现在，这并没有考虑到
magnitude of what it's overruling. It doesn't take account of, for instance, the Harvard and North Carolina affirmative action cases where they don't actually mouth those words were overruling. And it doesn't take account of cases that ought to be overruled. I mean, we certainly don't want Plessy and Korematsu and other parts of the court's shameful legacy to be in place. But in general, I take your point that this is a court that does not lack in self. self-confidence. And the so-called stare decisis factors, the criteria the court says it looks to
它所推翻的事物的严重性。它没有考虑到哈佛大学和北卡罗来纳大学的平权行动案件，在这些案件中他们实际上并没有说出“我们正在推翻”这些话。它也没有考虑到那些本应被推翻的案件。我的意思是，我们当然不希望普莱西案和科雷马图案以及法院耻辱历史的其他部分继续存在。但总的来说，我理解你的观点，即这是一个不缺乏自信的法院。
in deciding whether it overruled cases are really quite malleable. And, you know, starting with was the earlier decision egregiously wrong? Well, you know, that would seem to be in the eye of the beholder. Mm-hmm. You mentioned this idea of them being self-confident in their, in their, in their rulings. But sometimes when I, my interpretation is just a layperson watching is that they have actually a lack of confidence that they feel if they ever made a ruling that contradicted the executive branch that they kind of know they would lose and so therefore they're trying not to force a constitutional crisis. Am I off base there? Does that feel true at all? I think that is true, but it has not been true over time. I mean, I don't think they
所谓的“遵循先例”因素，即法院在决定是否推翻案件时声称所依据的标准，实际上是相当具可塑性的。而且，（你知道的）从先前的裁决是否“极其错误”开始。嗯，（你知道的）这似乎是见仁见智的事情。嗯嗯。你提到了他们对自己的裁决充满自信。但有时我的解释——作为一个旁观的门外汉——是他们实际上缺乏自信，觉得如果他们做出任何与行政分支相矛盾的裁决，他们心里知道自己会输，因此他们尽量不挑起宪法危机。我这种看法偏离事实吗？这听起来有一点真实吗？我认为这是真的，但随着时间推移并非总是如此。我的意思是，我不认为他们
were very much afraid of Joe Biden. Yeah. But we're now in an era where what was once inconceivable that a president would simply disobey a ruling of the Supreme Court is now at least plausible. I don't think likely, but at least plausible. Yeah. And do you think they make decisions with that fear in their mind
非常害怕乔·拜登。是的。但我们现在进入了一个时代，过去认为不可思议的事情——即总统会直接无视最高法院的裁决——现在至少是貌似合理的了。我不认为很可能，但至少是貌似合理的。是的。你认为他们在做出决定时，心里带着这种恐惧吗？
or thought in their mind? These are nine smart people and they live in the real world. I think another aspect of the court that maybe you can turn to things that aren't in Article 3 exactly, but really important to the way the Supreme Court works today. Maybe we could talk out of about standing, right? Let me go back for a moment and explain what I mean here. So standing is a legal doctrine that the Supreme Court has interpreted from the idea in Article 3 that the federal courts are supposed to only resolve cases and controversies. In other words, they can't just provide advice to folks. They have to have a real life case before them. So one aspect of this idea of a case or controversy is that people with real injuries and real injuries only can bring cases in federal court. So if you don't have a real
或者在他们脑海中闪过？这是九位聪明人，他们也生活在现实世界中。我认为最高法院的另一个方面是，你也许可以关注那些不完全在《宪法第三条》中，但对最高法院今天的运作方式至关重要的事情。也许我们可以谈谈诉讼资格（standing），对吧？让我回过头来解释一下我这里的意思。诉讼资格是一项法律学说，最高法院从《宪法第三条》的理念中解释出这一学说，即联邦法院应该只解决案件和争议。换句话说，他们不能只是向人们提供咨询意见。他们必须审理现实生活中的案件。因此，案件或争议这一理念的一个方面是，只有拥有实际伤害且仅有实际伤害的人才能在联邦法院提起诉讼。所以如果你没有实际
injury, you don't really have a case, and your case ought to be dismissed. So it seems to me that this is a big hurdle sometimes in the Roberts Court, but it's a very unpredictable hurdle, depending sometimes on what the issue is. I wonder what your thoughts are on standing and the Roberts Court. As with Sarticis, this is malleable and opportunistic. I mean, John Roberts used to be a standing hawk and really didn't think marginal cases in which people didn't have much of a direct stake ought to be brought before the court.
伤害，你其实就没有案件，你的案件理应被驳回。在我看来，这有时是罗伯茨法院（Roberts Court）的一大障碍，但这却是一个非常不可预测的障碍，有时取决于具体问题是什么。我很想听听你对诉讼资格以及罗伯茨法院的看法。正如对“遵循先例”（stare decisis）原则一样，这是可塑的且机会主义的。我的意思是，约翰·罗伯茨过去曾是诉讼资格的强硬派（standing hawk），确实认为人们没有多少直接利害关系的边缘案件不应该被提交到法院审理。
Just yesterday, as we're recording, he wrote an opinion in which a political candidate was found to have standing to challenge late-mailed ballots. And some people thought that was inconsistent with some of his earlier rulings. I might step back and say that our system is different from some other countries, this insistence, at least in theory, that we have an actual case or controversy, which is language from the Constitution, is not universal.
就在我们录音的昨天，他撰写了一份裁决意见，其中判定一名政治候选人具有对迟寄选票提出挑战的诉讼资格。有些人认为这与他早期的某些裁决前后矛盾。我可能会退一步说，我们的系统与其他一些国家不同，这种坚持——至少在理论上——我们必须拥有一个实际的案件或争议（这是宪法中的措辞），并不是普遍存在的。
There are constitutional courts around the world, which will answer questions in the abstract, or which will, you know, a legislature will say, we want to enact this law. Is it constitutional? And I don't know that that's a bad system. This insistence that we round up a plaintiff somewhere, that we're only going to decide if affirmative action is constitutional, if we can round up a 19-year-old who's willing to meet the face of, it's not obvious that that's the right way to run a judicial system. Yeah. But it is our way.
世界各地都有宪法法院，它们会回答抽象的问题，或者，你知道的，立法机构会说，我们想颁布这项法律。它合宪吗？我不知道这是一个糟糕的体制。这种坚持必须在某处找到一个原告，即我们只有在能够找到一个愿意出面面对的19岁年轻人的情况下，才去裁决平权行动是否合宪，这并不是理所当然的运营司法系统的正确方式。是的。但这就是我们的方式。
Yeah. I don't know if people really quite grasp that. Basically, that is required A, and B, how odd that really is when you think about it. Yeah, and maybe we could just put some, flesh this out just a little bit. I think, Adam, you know, what you might be referring to is, you know, there have been a couple of cases before the Roberts Court. for example, there was the case of the website designer. She said she was going to refuse to design a website for any same-sex couple who was going to ask her to design a website for their marriage.
是的。我不知道人们是否真的完全理解这一点。基本上，这是A所要求的，B，当你仔细想想时，这实际上是多么奇怪。是的，也许我们可以稍微补充说明一下。我认为，亚当，你知道的，你所指的可能是，你知道的，罗伯茨法院审理过几个案件。例如，有一个网站设计师的案子。她说她将拒绝为任何要求她为婚礼设计网站的同性恋伴侣设计网站。
There's a lawsuit involving her refusal, but the problem is she never created a website and no same-sex couple had ever actually asked her to create a website for their marriage. So it wasn't even clear what kind of controversy or dispute she had. So it seemed to a lot of folks before the Supreme Court heard that case, she doesn't have standing. How could she possibly have standing? But the Supreme Court didn't seem remotely bothered by this at all and went on to resolve the case in her favor. On the other hand, if you have an issue like we saw pretty recently during this administration, the shadow docket ruling about the roving immigration raids in Los Angeles, the court allowed the Trump administration to go forward with that. And Justice Kavanaugh wrote a long, concurring opinion explaining why he thought the district courts pause on those raids ought to be lifted. And one of the things he pointed out was, look, I don't even think that these folks have standing to ask for a forward-looking stay or an injunction on immigration officials. Again, you know, we could say that maybe these are principled uses of this doctrine, but they also seem to coincide with an agreement or deference.
有一场诉讼涉及她的这种拒绝，但问题是她从未创建过网站，也从来没有任何同性恋伴侣真正要求她为他们的婚礼创建一个网站。因此，甚至连她到底面临什么样的争议或纠纷都不清楚。所以在最高法院审理该案之前，许多人觉得她根本没有诉讼资格。她怎么可能具备诉讼资格呢？但最高法院似乎对这一点完全不在意，并继续作出了对她有利的判决。另一方面，如果你遇到了一个像我们在本届政府期间相当近的时候看到的问题——关于洛杉矶无预警移民搜查的影子 docket（shadow docket）裁决，法院允许特朗普政府继续推进该行动。卡瓦诺（Kavanaugh）大法官撰写了一篇长篇协同意见（concurring opinion），解释了他为什么认为地方法院对这些搜查令的暂停应该被解除。他指出的其中一点是，你看，我甚至不认为这些人有资格要求对移民官员发布前瞻性的暂缓令（stay）或禁令。再次说明，你知道的，我们可以说这些可能是对这一学说有原则的使用，但它们似乎也与对行政权力的同意或顺从不谋而合。
to executive power. Yeah, I mean, I could make the counter arguments in both cases, but I take your general point that this is not a doctrine that actually does a lot of work in keeping cases out of court that the court actually wants to decide. It can be a way to get rid of cases that doesn't want to cancel. Right, right. I mean, it seemed to be no hurdle to the court deciding whether or not President Biden could cancel billions of dollars of student debt.
是的，我的意思是，我在两个案件中都可以提出反驳论点，但我接受你的总体观点，即这并不是一项真正能在很大程度上将法院其实想要裁决的案件挡在门外的学说。它可以成为一种摆脱那些不想审理的案件的方法。对，对。我的意思是，这似乎对法院裁决拜登总统能否取消数十亿美元学生贷款构不成任何阻碍。
Based on some servicing companies attenuated interest and hundreds of millions of dollars turned on whether Mojillo was it? Right. The leader did not have standing. So a little bit of background. This is the student loan challenge to the cancellation of loans. And basically, the idea is, well, you know, the states argue that who brought this case. So you can't do that because you're going to reduce funds in the Treasury.
基于一些信贷服务公司微弱的利益，以及数亿美元取决于莫吉拉（Mojila）是谁？对。该领导人没有诉讼资格。所以，一点背景知识。这是针对贷款取消的学生贷款挑战。基本上，其想法是，好吧，你知道，各州争论是谁提起这个诉讼。所以你不能这么做，因为你会减少财政部的资金。
That's the classic, you can't bring this kind of lawsuit. You're just yelling at the TV kind of lawsuit, right? But Missouri said, well, we created this independent nonprofit called Mojila, and they service the loans. And if the loans are canceled, then this independent nonprofit suffers an economic harm. I mean, it wasn't even a party in the case. But nevertheless, as Adam points out, I think the Supreme Court really wanted to decide this case. So conveniently, it was thought that there was standing and sufficient standing for the case to be decided.
那是典型的“你不能提起这种诉讼”的情况。这就像是对着电视大喊大叫的那种诉讼，对吧？但密苏里州说，好吧，我们成立了一个名为莫吉拉（Mojila）的独立非营利组织，他们负责提供贷款服务。如果贷款被取消，那么这个独立非营利组织就会遭受经济损失。我的意思是，它甚至都不是案件当事人。但尽管如此，正如亚当所指出的，我认为最高法院非常想对这个案件做出裁决。因此顺理成章地，人们认为存在诉讼资格，并且有足够的诉讼资格来对该案进行裁决。
That's amazing. I want to ask you a little bit about covering the court and interpreting it for people for your paper. You know, these decisions, they're long. They are complicated to read. And you have to digest them and report them very, very quickly. Could you talk about the challenge of that? You know, Anthony Lewis, the great Supreme Court reporter, used to tell me you spend many months getting ready for a few days in June. So if you're doing your job right, you will have read the briefs at the early stage of when the parties are asking the court to hear or not hear the case.
这太神奇了。我想问你一些关于报道法院以及为你的报纸向人们解释法院的问题。你知道，这些判决很长。阅读起来很复杂。你必须消化它们，并非常、非常迅速地报道它们。你能谈谈这其中的挑战吗？你知道，伟大的最高法院记者安东尼·刘易斯（Anthony Lewis）过去常常告诉我，你花了许多个月的时间来为6月的几天做准备。所以如果你工作做得对的话，在诉讼当事人要求法院审理或不审理案件的早期阶段，你就已经阅读了诉讼简报（briefs）。
you'll write a story about the court's decision to hear the case. You'll maybe do a set-up piece on the parties to the case. You'll go to the argument. You'll read the briefs in connection with the merits briefing. Write a story about the argument. You will have steeped yourself in the mechanics of it. And I should also say that if you do it long enough, the court tends to decide the same set of issues over and over again. So you have a pretty good sense of how they think about things.
你会写一篇关于法院决定审理此案的报道。你可能会写一篇关于案件当事人的背景文章。你会去听辩论。你会阅读与实体问题简报（merits briefing）相关的简报。写一篇关于辩论的报道。你将自己沉浸在它的运作机制中。我还应该说，如果你做的时间够长，法院往往会一遍又一遍地裁决同一组问题。所以你对他们思考问题的方式有了相当不错的直觉。
And then as the decisions approach, you write alternative drafts of how it might come out, or more strictly speaking, you write what journalists call B matter, which is just background material that's going to be the same regardless of what they do. And in the earliest versions of the stories, basically just a who won and who lost. And in a really big story, we will publish, you know, within a matter of minutes, assuming that I can figure out at least that much. Who won and who lost? A very quick story. And then almost immediately go back in with a vote count and a couple of quotes. And only then sit down and it might take me an hour to really read the decision with care
然后随着判决日期的临近，你写出关于判决结果可能如何的备用草案，或者更严格地说，你写的是记者们所说的B级素材（B matter），这只是一些无论他们做什么都保持不变的背景材料。而在报道的最早版本中，基本上就是谁赢了谁输了。对于一篇真正的大报道，我们会（在假设我至少能弄明白这么多的前提下）在几分钟内发表。谁赢了谁输了？一篇非常简短的报道。然后几乎立即返回，补充投票统计结果和几句引言。直到那时才坐下来，我可能需要花一个小时才能真正仔细阅读判决书
and get a sense of its architecture and the dialogue between the dissent and majority and concurrences, if there are any, and a sense of where this fits in doctrinally and what the consequences might be. And then by, you know, the early middle afternoon, try to give birth to the first actually valuable story. The first one is not like wire service. And then by the end of the day, you hope you've written something. that will stand the test of time and will be in the archives and will be of some use to somebody. But unfortunately, there's a real inverse relationship between quality and readership. So the first story gets an enormous readership and the last story, which you take some pride in,
并把握其架构、异议意见（dissent）与多数意见（majority）以及协同意见（concurrences，如果有的话）之间的对话，以及把握这在法律学说上契合何处以及可能产生什么后果。然后到，你知道的，下午早些时候到中部时间下午，努力产出第一篇真正有价值的报道。第一篇不像电讯社稿件那样。然后到一天结束时，你希望你写出了一些经得起时间考验、会进入档案馆并对某人有所帮助的东西。但遗憾的是，质量和读者群之间存在着真正的反比例关系。所以第一篇报道获得了庞大的读者群，而你为此感到自豪的最后一篇报道，
rather less so. Are there ever back-channel messages you get, you know, that somehow will come from the court, that they disagreed with what you said or thought you did a great summary or anything like that? It would probably be more of the first than the second. Has the nature, I mean, maybe I'm just more aware of them now, but the dissents seem to take on more of a, I don't know,
你是否曾经收到过一些暗中传达的信息（back-channel messages），你知道的，某种程度上来自法院，说他们不同意你的说法，或者认为你做了一个很棒的总结之类的？这可能是第一种情况多于第二种情况。这种性质——我的意思是，也许我只是现在对它们更有意识了——但异议意见似乎呈现出更多的一种，我不知道，
a harsher tone, I guess, as the way I would say it, or have a lot going on in them. Am I just more aware or has that always been the case? I think there's a quality, to the dissents these days from the three Justice Democratic appointee liberal minority that is the product of hopelessness in just being on a never-ending losing streak. Yeah. That is different from when, you know, there were four of them and they could pick up
一种更严厉的语气，我想这就是我的表达方式，或者其中有很多激烈的内容。是我只是更有意识了，还是情况一直如此？我认为，现今来自三位民主党任命的大法官组成的自由派少数派的异议意见具有某种品质，这是由于身处无休止的败局中所产生的绝望感所导致的产物。是的。这与当年，你知道的，当他们有四个人并且可以时不时争取到
Kennedy's vote from time to time. It's just got a different feel to it. And the stakes may be thought to be higher in some ways. So I agree that it's got a different tone. That said, you know, Justice Scalia in dissent could write some pretty sharp things. That's right. So do you have a sense that, you know, there's a lot of discussion about what happens after Trump and further discussion about it with a Democratic president, change the composition of the court?
肯尼迪（Kennedy）的投票时的情况有所不同。它的感觉就是不一样。在某些方面，利害关系可能被认为更高。所以我同意它的基调有所不同。话虽如此，你知道的，斯卡利亚（Scalia）大法官在发表异议时确实能写出一些相当犀利的言辞。没错。那么你是否有这样一种感觉，你知道的，有很多关于特朗普之后会发生什么以及与民主党总统进一步讨论的讨论，会改变法院的构成吗？
Do you think it's as simple as that, that, you know, changing the majority could sort of undo some of what's been done during the Roberts era, or are we headed in a totally different direction? I think a change in personnel would, in short order, move the court in a different direction, jurisprudentially. There was a moment in time, you'll remember, when it looked like President Obama would be able to replace Justice Scalia with Merrick Garland. He didn't get a hearing in the end. But political scientists predicted that if that happened, cases like Citizens United and Heller on the Second Amendment could well be reversed.
你认为事情就这么简单吗，你知道的，改变多数派可以某种程度上撤销罗伯茨时代所做的一些事情，还是我们正朝着一个完全不同的方向前进？我认为人员的变动会在短时间内在法理学层面上将法院推向一个不同的方向。你会记得，曾几何时，看起来奥巴马总统将能够用梅里克·加兰（Merrick Garland）取代斯卡利亚大法官。他最终没有得到听证会。但政治学家预测，如果发生这种情况，像《联合公民案》（Citizens United）和关于第二修正案的《海勒案》（Heller）等判决很可能会被推翻。
It's entirely conceivable. I mean, stare decisis is a game two sides can play. But at great risk of really undermining the court's legitimacy, don't you think? I guess, although, you know, we talk about the court's legitimacy, and the court has been quite active. And its approval ratings have fallen some. but in truth, they're still higher than most of the rest of the government. The military is higher, but Congress is in the toilet. It's higher than journalists. Probably higher than the academy.
这完全是可以想象的。我的意思是，遵循先例（stare decisis）是双方都可以玩的游戏。但在极大地威胁法院合法性的巨大风险下，你不这么认为吗？我猜，尽管，你知道的，我们讨论法院的合法性，而且法院一直相当活跃。其支持率有所下降。但在现实中，它们仍然高于政府的大多数其他部门。军方的支持率更高，但国会简直烂透了（in the toilet）。它比记者高。可能比学术界还要高。
Right, for sure. And I mean, at the end of the day, I think all legitimacy means is, will people do what the court says? And so far, there's no indication that people won't. Do you think that the idea of legitimacy, which I only hear in reference to the judicial branch, or the idea of reason and logic being the ruling principle, is that a consequence of the vagueness of Article 3 that's built on top of kind of we're building our foundation as it during the creation of the thing, you know, in a way? So it has to have some other sort of foundation to stand on. I think that's a good point. And a little too abstract for the likes of my simple-mindedness.
对，当然。我的意思是，归根结底，我认为合法性的全部意义就在于：人们会听从法院的话吗？到目前为止，没有任何迹象表明人们不会。你认为合法性的概念——我只在提及司法部门时听到过——或者理性与逻辑是统治原则的概念，是《宪法第三条》模糊性的一种后果，这种模糊性建立在我们边创建事物边奠定基础的过程中，你知道的，某种程度上？因此它必须有其他某种基础来立足。我认为这是一个很好的观点。而对于我这种思维简单的人来说，这有点太抽象了。
Fair enough. Well, you know, one thing to think about with legitimacy, though, is I think there's a, you know, there's a tension here with the courts have to be legitimate. That's part of their independence. At the same time, I think a lot of individual, some individual federal judges feel under threat or under attack. And I want to go back for a moment to Chief Justice Roberts, who said, I believe that is 2024. end of the year report, he openly acknowledged that, look, you can't, you can't threaten the judiciary. That is unacceptable, right? And then this just past year's report, he had a kind of rosy-colored vision of the country's 250th birthday. And I just, it's such a swing back and forth. Where do you see
这倒也是。好吧，你知道，关于合法性，有一件事需要思考，那就是我认为这里存在着一种紧张关系，法院必须具有合法性。这是他们独立性的一部分。与此同时，我认为许多个人，一些联邦法官感到自己受到了威胁或攻击。我想回过头来谈谈罗伯茨首席大法官，我相信那是2024年的年底报告，他公开承认，看，你不能，你不能威胁司法部门。那是不可接受的，对吧？然后就在去年的报告中，他对国家成立250周年抱有一种玫瑰色的愿景。我只是觉得，这种前后摇摆太大了。你认为
your sense of how the judiciary is responding, sometimes to literal threats, sometimes to social media threats of impeachment, things of that nature? I don't know what to say other than that these threats are real. The judiciary is quite concerned about them. The Supreme Court has excellent security. Lower court judges, much less so. They're deeply concerned about it. I think the Chief Justice should speak out about it often and robustly.
司法部门的反应如何，有时是对字面上的威胁的反应，有时是对社交媒体上弹劾威胁等性质事情的反应？除了这些威胁是真实存在的之外，我不知道还能说些什么。司法部门对此非常关切。最高法院拥有极佳的安保。下级法院的法官则远没有那么好。他们对此深感担忧。我认为首席大法官应该经常且有力地对此大声疾呼。
I don't think it's affecting their work, but I don't know. it's different in kind from anything I've lived through before. Political violence is, I guess it's always been with us, but it seems to be woven into the texture of ordinary American life these days in a way that's really disturbing. More with the New York Times, Adam Liptack. After the break. If there's something that, you know, you would change,
我不认为这正在影响他们的工作，但我不知道。这与我以前经历过的任何事情在本质上都不同。政治暴力，我猜它一直伴随着我们，但它现在似乎已经编织进了普通美国人生活的纹理中，这真的很令人不安。更多内容请关注《纽约时报》的亚当·利普塔克（Adam Liptack）。广告之后继续。如果有什么事情，你知道的，你会去改变的话，
what do you think is the right way to make things better? I know you're a reporter and your, You're just trying to tell the story of what happened. But as you see it close up, what do you think would be like an effective way to make the Supreme Court more effective or the decisions make more sense? You know, reporters always want transparency. Yeah. I would love to know, for instance, the vote counts on these emergency applications we were talking about earlier or when the court decides not to hear a case, how many justices voted for that or not. They also have a tendency. It's not the world's hardest working court. I mean, they issue maybe 60 decisions on the merits a year. But they do tend to do everything all at the same time. So there are days when they agree to hear cases and issue opinions and hear arguments and then they go away for two weeks.
你认为让事情变得更好的正确方式是什么？我知道你是一名记者，你的，你只是想讲述发生了什么的故事。但从你近距离的观察来看，你认为能让最高法院更有效率或者让判决更有意义的有效方法会是什么？你知道，记者总是追求透明度。是的。比如，我很想知道我们之前讨论过的这些紧急申请的投票统计数据，或者当法院决定不审理某个案件时，有多少大法官投了赞成票或反对票。他们也有这样一种倾向。这并不是世界上最勤奋的法院。我的意思是，他们每年大概只对实体问题做出大约60项判决。但他们确实往往把所有事情都在同一时间堆在一起。所以有些日子里，他们同意审理案件、发布意见书、听取辩论，然后他们就离开两周。
If they were to space those things out a little bit, that would be nice. Do you think it would be a good idea if the Supreme Court arguments were televised live? I'm in favor of that. It's an academic question only. It's not going to happen. I don't think it would add a whole lot. You know, it's an open government proceeding. It ought to be open to the public in the realest sense imaginable. That said, the live audio, which is an artifact of the pandemic and would have been unimaginable 10 years ago, gets you 95% of the way. Certainly if you can recognize the justice as voices. You're really getting almost all the information that you need. I think some of the justices value their privacy, although their book tours would seem to cut in the other direction. But that's not a legitimate reason, not to have cameras. Some of them say goofy things on the bench,
如果他们能把这些事情稍微间隔开一点，那就好了。你认为最高法院的辩论进行电视直播会是一个好主意吗？我对此表示赞成。这纯粹是一个学术问题。这不会发生。我不认为这会增加多少内容。你知道的，这是一场公开的政府诉讼。它本应以你能想象得到的、最真实意义上的方式向公众开放。话虽如此，现场音频（这是大流行的产物，在10年前是不可想象的）已经能带你达到95%的效果。当然，如果你能认出大法官的声音的话。你实际上得到了你所需几乎所有的信息。我认为一些大法官很珍视他们的隐私，尽管他们的图书巡回宣传似乎指向相反的方向。但这不是不安装摄像头的正当理由。他们中的一些人在法庭上说一些愚蠢的话，
and they're afraid that that would turn up on late-night television. That's an authentic concern, but not a legitimate one. Are there security concerns around this? I don't know. But anyway, I mean, this is a thought exercise only. They're not going to do it. So putting its constitutionally aside, one thought I'd had is, you know, would it be better for the system if the justices were just told, look, when you hear argument, you have to issue an opinion, you know, let's say a month later. And the reason I raise this is because, you know, as you say, Trump versus the United States, the presidential immunity opinions, maybe the most significant decision of the court so far. and they waited. They waited until the very, very end,
他们担心这些话会出现在深夜电视节目中。这是一个真实的担忧，但不是一个正当的担忧。这周围是否存在安全隐患？我不知道。但无论如何，我的意思是，这只是一种思想实验。他们不会这么做的。所以撇开宪法不谈，我曾有过的一个想法是，你知道的，如果告诉大法官们：看，当你听取辩论时，你必须在一个月左右后发表意见，这对体制会不会更好？我提出这一点的原因是，你知道的，正如你所说，特朗普诉美国案（Trump versus the United States）、总统豁免权意见，可能是迄今为止法院最重要的判决。而他们等了。他们一直等到非常、非常最后的时候，
and that timing made it impossible for anything really to go on in the case at all. And, you know, that was presumably deliberate or they couldn't come to an agreement on things. I'd love to hear your thoughts on that. So I think the idea of making them work fast as a general proposition is a bad idea. They don't do good work working fast.
而这个时机使得该案根本不可能再进行任何实质性的审理。而且，你知道的，这大概是故意的，或者他们在某些问题上无法达成一致。我很想听听你对此的想法。所以，我认为普遍要求他们快速工作的想法是个坏想法。他们在快速工作时做不出好作品。
And I actually give them some credit, and not every court is like this, disposing of every merits case, almost without exception, within the October to June term. What they might have done in Trump against the United States is, you remember, Jack Smith went to the court twice, once a procedure called cert before judgment seeking to leapfrog the D.C. Circuit. I think back in October. Very early. And they turned that down. And if they had taken the case then rather than later,
而且我实际上对他们给予了一些肯定，并非每个法院都像这样，他们几乎无一例外地在10月至6月的开庭期内处理了每一个实体案件。他们在《特朗普诉美国案》中可能做过的是，你还记得，杰克·史密斯（Jack Smith）曾两次找最高法院，一次是通过一种名为“判决前移审令”（cert before judgment）的程序，试图跳过华盛顿特区巡回上诉法院。我想是在10月份。非常早。而他们拒绝了。如果他们当时而不是后来接手这个案件，
they might have had some running room to issue a decision and maybe a more considered decision. April arguments almost always yield pretty poor decisions. It's just not enough time for them. And they've already backed up on everything else. So April arguments and June decisions don't tend to be at the court's best work. Hmm. Interesting. Is there anything else sort of, you know, from your vantage point, the way the court works that is interesting or surprising to you as you've been covering this for so long? You know, I'm so close to it. I probably don't realize what I should, which should be interesting or surprising.
他们可能就会有一些腾挪的空间来发布判决，也许是一个经过更多深思熟虑的判决。4月份的辩论几乎总是产生相当糟糕的判决。对他们来说时间实在是不够。而且他们已经在所有其他事情上都积压了。所以4月份的辩论和6月份的判决往往不是法院的最佳水准。嗯。有趣。从你的角度来看，在你报道了这么长时间之后，法院运作的方式中还有没有什么其他让你觉得有趣或惊讶的事情？你知道的，我离它太近了。我可能没有意识到什么本该是有趣或惊奇的事情。
I guess I should say that I kind of stepped back from Daily Beat reporting at the end of this last. term. So I have, I'm still writing about the court, but not on this kind of daily ruling basis. My colleagues, Ann Merrimow and Abby Van Sickle have taken over the hardest part of the job. And I'm more of an analytical observer. So I'm, I'm kind of decompressing from 17 years of Supreme Court charge. Like, would people be surprised by how much, like, clerks do versus justice is and things like this. The justices each have four Brainiac law clerks.
我想我应该说，我在上一个开庭期结束时，从每日突发新闻报道（Daily Beat reporting）中退居二线了。所以我现在，我仍在撰写关于法院的文章，但不是以这种日常裁决为基础的。我的同事安·麦里莫（Ann Marimow）和艾比·范西克尔（Abby Van Sickle）接手了这项工作中最高难度部分。而我更像是一个分析观察家。所以我在，我正在从17年的最高法院报道生涯中放松下来。比如，人们会对法官和法官助理（clerks）各自做了多少工作感到惊讶吗，诸如此类的事情。每位大法官都有四名聪明绝顶的法律助理。
Who work around the clock. Yeah. Well, maybe we could pause for a moment. Maybe we could just explain. What do you mean by a clerk? Maybe readers will think, oh, someone who writes down appointments for the justices. What do you mean by a clerk? So these clerkships are one year long.
他们日夜工作。嗯，也许我们可以暂停一下。也许我们可以简单解释一下。你所说的助理（clerk）是什么意思？也许读者会想，哦，就是给大法官记预约的人。你所说的助理是什么意思？所以这些助理职位为期一年。
They are given to young people who are law school graduates and who have typically clerked for one, now sometimes two lower court judges. They will have the most distinguished resumes imaginable and excellent grades and great skills, but maybe not yet great maturity. And they are given extraordinary responsibilities, including in evaluating the petition seeking review, which are sent out to the so-called cert pool where a single 26-year-old makes a preliminary judgment for the Supreme Court of the United States
它们授予那些法学院毕业的年轻人，他们通常担任过一名，现在有时是两名下级法院法官的助理。他们拥有你能想象到的最杰出的简历、优秀的成绩和出色的技能，但可能还没有足够的高度成熟。他们被赋予了非凡的职责，包括评估寻求审查的请愿书，这些请愿书被发送到所谓的审理池（cert pool），在那里，一个26岁的年轻人为美国最高法院做出初步判断，
about whether to grant review or not. And, you know, these clerks make up a little law firm with the justice at its head. And as in a real law firm, the associates write the first draft of a brief or an opinion. And the justice is directed and, you know, are responsible for it. And most of them write through it fairly carefully.
决定是否批准审查。而且，你知道的，这些助理与以大法官为首的法官构成了一个小型律师事务所。正如在真正的律师事务所里一样，初级律师（associates）撰写简报或判决书的第一稿。而大法官则进行指导，你知道的，并对此负责。他们大多数人都相当仔细地通读并修改了这些稿件。
But the clerk has a substantial hand in what happens. Not at all contemplated by Article III. We'll search in vain for law clerk in the Constitution. Yes, it is a remarkable aspect of the, judiciary that, you know, it's not, what you're mentioning is, of course, the most important clerks at the top of the heap on the Supreme Court, but every federal judge has one or more clerks who serve in the same role.
但助理对事情的走向有很大的插手。这根本不在《宪法第三条》的设想之中。你在宪法里翻遍也找不到“法律助理”这个词。是的，这是司法部门的一个显著方面，你知道的，这不是——你所提及的当然是最高法院顶端最重要的助理，但每一个联邦法院法官都有一名或多名担任同样角色的助理。
Well, you know, one thing we haven't talked about is the background of the justices, which is increasingly turning into a kind of inherited aristocracy. Say more about that, please. I mean, the justices themselves have sterling resumes, eight of the nine went to Harvard or Yale, law school, and several of them not only clerked on the Supreme Court. I mean, the odds of that are sort of vanishingly small. There's not that many clerkships to go around, but two of them, three of them, three of them clerked for the very justice whom they succeeded. Right.
好吧，你知道，我们还没谈到的一件事是大法官的背景，这正日益变成一种世袭贵族制。请多谈谈这一点。我的意思是，大法官们本身拥有极佳的简历，九人中有八人毕业于哈佛或耶鲁法学院，其中几人不仅在最高法院担任过助理。我的意思是，这种概率简直微乎其微。没有那么多助理职位可供分配，但其中两人，三人，三他们三人担任过他们所接替的那位大法官的助理。对。
I mean, that's curious, but Roberts for Rehnquist and Jackson for Breyer, and, Kavanaugh for Kennedy? I mean, what are the odds of that? And that ties back a little bit to the point I was making earlier about timing of retirements. I don't have evidence for this, but I think it may be possible that as a justice is deciding whether to retire or not, that justice might have consultations with the White House and say, you know, I might like to retire and it sure be nice if you would appoint my favorite clerk to succeed me. And it's remarkable because, of course, in other aspects of the Constitution, we have, for instance, prohibitions on granting titles of nobility because that very value is something the founders said, we don't want that system. And yet it's crept into the Supreme Court, as you mentioned.
我的意思是，这很奇妙，但罗伯茨是伦奎斯特（Rehnquist）的助理，杰克逊（Jackson）是布雷耶（Breyer）的助理，卡瓦诺是肯尼迪的助理？我的意思是，这种概率有多大？这稍微回溯到了我之前提出的关于退休时机的一点。我没有证据证明这一点，但我认为有这种可能，即当一位大法官在决定是否退休时，这位大法官可能会与白宫进行协商，并说，你知道，我可能想退休，如果你能任命我最喜欢的助理来接替我，那就太好了。这很了不起，因为当然，在宪法的其他方面，我们有，例如，关于禁止授予贵族称号的规定，因为正是这种价值观，奠基人们说过：我们不想要那种体制。然而它却悄悄潜入了最高法院，正如你所提到的。
It is remarkable to me, too, in the sense that like even in the sort of the text itself, the idea of lifetime appointments, in a constitution that is full of things that are basically guards against any type of thing that smacks is. as monarchy. Like in terms of even the age of the president can be, it's kind of a backdoor way of, you know, like George Washington not giving it to a six-year-old kid in the presidency. And this is an odd thing that we've set up this side channel where these titles of nobility are our lifetime and can be, you know, functionally passed on is an oddity. Right. Well, one last thing maybe we should address is, you know, this Article III is very, very short. And strangely enough, in this very short part of the Constitution, there's an entire section voted to treason, which seems to totally be a non-sequitur. It has nothing to do with the preceding part of Article 3.
在我看来这也是非同寻常的，就像即使在文本本身中一样，终身任职的概念，在一份充满各种基本上可以防止任何带有君主制气息的东西的保障措施的宪法中。比如甚至对总统年龄的限制，这是一种迂回的方式，你知道的，就像乔治·华盛顿没有把总统职位交给一个六岁的小孩一样。而这是一件奇怪的事情，我们设立了这个侧通道，这些贵族头衔是终身的，并且可以，你知道的，在功能上往下传递，这是一个奇特之处。好吧，也许我们应该解决的最后一件事情是，你知道的，这个《宪法第三条》非常、非常短。而且很奇怪的是，在这篇非常短的宪法篇章中，有一整节专门留给叛国罪（treason），这似乎完全是一个离题的话题。它与《宪法第三条》前面部分毫无关系。
Maybe we can talk about that for a moment if you have thoughts on it. You wonder if the drafters were going, well, we've got to talk about treason somewhere. Where shall we stick it? That's right. I mean, I suppose it's a crime. It would be adjudicated in court. It's a federal crime. But yes, I mean, Article 3 has three sections. Section 3 is about treason.
如果我们对它有想法的话，也许我们可以讨论一会儿。你会纳闷，起草者当时是不是在想，好吧，我们必须在某个地方谈论叛国罪。我们把它塞到哪里呢？没错。我的意思是，我猜它是一项罪行。它将在法庭上受审。这是一项联邦罪行。但是的，我的意思是，《宪法第三条》有三节。第三节是关于叛国罪的。
Yeah. Right. And also very important to the founders to make sure that whatever the punishment was, it was only for the lifetime of the person convicted of treason. There shall not be corruption of the blood, which was an English common law term, you know, referring to we can't punish people for generations for having a treasonous member of their family. Just a very strange place to put this strict definition. of treason in the Constitution. Well, one thing we haven't talked about is the article does talk about the court's original
是的。没错。而且对国父们来说非常重要的是，要确保无论惩罚是什么，它都只针对被判叛国罪之人的有生之年。不得株连血脉（corruption of the blood），这是一个英国普通法术语，（你知道的，指的是我们不能因为家里有一个犯了叛国罪的成员而惩罚好几代人）。把叛国罪的严格定义放在宪法里，真是一个非常奇怪的地方。好吧，我们还没有谈到的一点是，该条确实谈到了法院的原始管辖权（original jurisdiction）。所以法院基本上是，并且在今天几乎完全是一个上诉法院。并审理下面已经裁决过的案件，它只处理法律问题是否得到了正确的裁决。让我在这方面扯远一点。法院也是——这是一个相当现代的发展——裁决它将只裁决离散的法律问题。它不接受案件的上诉。
jurisdiction. So the court is basically, and these days almost entirely, an appeals court. And here's cases that have been decided below, and it just deals with whether the legal issues were correctly decided. Let me digress on that a bit. The court is also, and this is a fairly modern development, decided that it. it will only decide discrete questions of law. It doesn't take an appeal of a case.
它接受对提出的离散问题的上诉。但无论如何，它所裁决的任何内容通常都是法律性的。但宪法也设想，至少在某些情况下，它将充当审判法院（trial court），裁决事实并听取证人陈述。而在今天，这几乎总是涉及各州之间的争端，通常是关于边界、水权等等。事实上，法院并没有坐下来听取证人陈述、敲击法槌并听取异议等等，而是任命了一位特别主事官（special master）来做这方面的工作。
It takes appeals of discrete questions presented. But in any event, whatever it's deciding is generally legal. But the Constitution also contemplates that in at least some cases, it will act as a trial court and adjudicate facts and hear witnesses. And these days, that almost always involves disputes between states, often about boundaries or water rights or so on. And the court doesn't, in fact, sit and hear witnesses and, you know, bang the gavel and hear objections and so on, but appoints a special master who does some version of that.
但我认为制宪先例可能设想了一个在相当大比例的时间里充当审判法院的法院。是的，想到这一点真是疯狂。如果这种传统延续至今，你会看到这些低调的案件，比如会传唤证人，而大法官们会做点什么。部分原因只是，我猜，你知道的，就像许多其他事情一样，这只是一种历史实践的问题。法院将承担大量原始管辖权案件或审判类型案件的想法，由于法院在多代人中不希望这样做而逐渐消退。
But I think the framers probably contemplated a court that would act as a trial court some substantial amount of the time. Yeah, that's wild to think about that. That would be carried to this day, that you'd see these low-profile cases. that would be like witnesses would be called and the justices would do something. And part of it is just, I guess, you know, as so many other things, it's just a matter of historical practice. The idea that the court would take on a lot of original jurisdiction cases or trial type cases, kind of as ebbed away through the court just not wanting to do that over many generations.
对。亚当·利普塔克，和你的交谈真是太有趣了。我非常感谢你抽出时间以及你的见解，而且我很喜欢阅读你的作品。非常感谢你来到这里。和你们交谈让我感到非常兴奋。谢谢你们。是的，这非常有趣。非常感谢。
Right. Adam Leptek, it's been such fun talking with you. I really appreciate the time and your insight and I love reading your work. Thank you so much for being here. I got a real kick out of talking with you guys. Thank you. Yeah, that was a lot of fun. Thank you so much.
请加入我们下个月的节目。我们将进入《宪法第四条》，全部关于州与州之间的关系，以及州与联邦政府之间的关系。《99%隐形宪法解密》（The 99% Invisible breakdown on the Constitution）由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作，委员会编辑。音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）完成。凯茜·2（Kathy 2）是我们的执行制片人。科urt·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁韦（Chris Perube）、
Join us next month. We're moving on to Article 4, all about the relationship between the states and the relationship between states and the federal government. The 99% of visible breakdown on the Constitution was produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee. Music by Swan Real, Mix by Martine Gonzalez. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Perube,
杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、博沙·马顿（Bosha Maddon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利（Tallin and Rain Stradley），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。该系列的插图由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。我们是天狼星XM播客（Series XM podcast family）家族的一部分，总部现在位于北面六个街区外的潘多拉大楼（Pandora building）。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。
Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Boschamaddon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallin and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are a part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California.
你可以在所有常见的社交网站上找到这个节目，以及他们自己的Discord服务器，我们在那里就宪法、建筑、电影和音乐以及各种好东西进行有趣的讨论。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 的每一集过往节目。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as their own Discord, server where we have fun discussions about constitutional law, about architecture, about movies and music and all kinds of good stuff. You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在各大常用社交媒体平台上找到本节目，也可以加入我们的专属Discord服务器，在那里我们愉快地讨论宪法、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种精彩内容。您可以在 99PI.org 上找到加入Discord服务器的链接以及 99PI 的所有往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。